[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Elemental
Gardens this is a small park which I'll
be working on throughout this week and
I'll be releasing one episode every day
basically in preparation for PAX East in
Boston which is happening at the end of
this week now what's going to happen at
PAX East if you might have guessed or
you might know already is that frontier
is going to go out there to showcase
planet coaster and there is going to be
some super exciting stuff happening
where can I get some developer streams
with some glimpses of the new update and
some streamers and youtubers also coming
up I'm trying not to be too obviously
plugging the events here but obviously
it is actually what I'm making this part
for basically I got approached and asked
if I could make a park that could be
used to showcase the game at PAX not
just for anybody who's right there at
the booth and wants to play it but also
for the streamers for instance and that
is basically what I'll be doing
in this series that's also why it's
somewhat short and definitely a bit
different from what I'm usually doing
since there are quite a few conditions
that I have to keep in mind here and I'm
really trying to work around the
limitations as much as I can but still
it's a project it's got a few episodes
we've got time lapses and stuff being
built and I think it's fun to have a
sort of themed week in that sense so
without further ado let's get into it
all right now as you might have guessed
from the opening shops in this episode
I'll be working on an observation tower
this thing is going to sit right in the
middle of the park
kind of like the Disney Land Council or
the Eiffel Tower in Kings Island I
believe and it's basically going to be
the main wing of the park and a really
the only icon that it has going for it
and sort of large structures that will
be visible from the entire park but also
you can see the entire park from the top
of the observation tower now there are a
few things that I definitely have to
keep in mind here for one there is no
observation tower in the game itself so
I just had to kind of make it out of
puff
kind of make it functional that way it
doesn't mean that in the end barely
anyone is actually going to use this
observation tower even with a attraction
point on the top of it for entertainers
it doesn't really get people to the top
of it but realistically you could walk
all of these stairs and get to the top
of the observation tower and actually
look at the rest of the park what's more
important though is then I'm trying to
sort of circumvent some of the
limitations that I really had to keep in
mind in this point one of them was not
using too many pieces since this is a
park that's meant to show of the game
and if anything most of my parks break
the game and use thousands of pieces in
buildings in a way that you're not
supposed to and totally destroys the
frame rate I wanted to actually keep
this gameplay friendly and make sure
that I wouldn't have to sacrifice on any
performance so the entire park is going
to not use too many pieces and because
of that I wanted some kind of central
very detailed building which is unique
to sort of make up words like that I
can't really have a very immersive or
detailed theming around the park as a
whole so this structure in a sense with
a very unique shape and quite some
detailing should hopefully make up for
that a little bit and that is part of
the idea there's also the fact that I
simply had to make this Park in kind of
short amount of time and it really
consists of only just a few episodes as
build an entire park and in terms of
playtime almost half of that was making
this building and the main street the
entrance in the entrance area so a lot
of the detailed and important building
is just in one spot here and the rest of
the park is just going to be very
generic just rides with foliage but not
so much scenery otherwise so I just
wanted to make a statement I guess with
this tower and make it as visible as
possible and like one way to make sure
that the plug stands out without having
to spend too much time on all kinds of
scenery and all kinds of detailing
because there was no way I could
actually do that
so onto the design of the actual tower
itself that they met quite interesting
well what I always found super weird
about this tower is that I never quite
could place my finger on it like why it
seems so familiar but it always seems
like a very familiar building to me and
in hindsight I think it has a very
striking similarity to the Pearl
Roundabout in Bahrain which doesn't
exist anymore but it's a roundabout
centerpiece and it kind of has a very
similar shape to it I've also heard many
people kind of refer to it as something
that's similar to the Olympic flame
though I'm on the olympic torch I guess
but I'm not entirely sure which one that
is and I haven't really been able to
find any that look like this my initial
inspiration was the what's it called in
Seattle Graham the Space Needle my
initial inspiration was kind of having a
Space Needle a scrolling with these
pillars on the bottom and actually
observation deck with glass windows and
everything on the top but that ended up
becoming like an idea that was both a
bit too bulky and also just seemed like
a blatant ripoff so I wanted to do
something that is very different from
that so I also took some inspiration
from the Canton tower in China which has
a sort of similar silhouette to this
tower and in the end kind of came up
with this design and it was also for
practical reasons a design that's quite
easy to make because all I had to do was
make one sort of curved side pillar and
copy that one around six times
make sure it's rotated right and that
basically makes the entire design of the
tower the spiral staircase is also just
really simple to make with some paths
and doesn't consist of any pieces so
everything is quite quickly built and of
it well it has a very small amount of
pieces but still I'm actually really
happy with the way that the tower came
out it's kind of difficult to come up
with an observation tower that is both
unique and somewhat sleek I guess and
could also still in terms of skill fit
into a theme
because I also didn't want to make it
too big and this power is already quite
sizable at 196 major store but in the
end I am actually really happy with how
it turned out and the rest of this
episode will just be some very general
detailing and making sure that the area
around the tower itself is all right so
one of the things that I wanted to do
was to get some lights in on the side of
the building I remember a while ago I
made the accelerator coaster and this
was until have a sort of similar style
to it
I think it definitely could fit together
with it but I saw somebody on reddit
take the accelerator and add some things
to it because at the time when I make
the accelerator it was still in alpha I
think it was alpha 2 but in Monaca
number 3 is well yeah I think it was
alpha 3 but any case we only had a
thousand blueprint pieces
so basically blueprints weren't allowed
to go over a thousand scenery pieces and
I hit that xx border with accelerator
but somebody later picked it up and
added some lights to the sides and was
something that looks really amazing like
having this sort of neon light to it and
I reckon that was something that I could
try with the tower over here as well so
I took some inspiration from that and
made sure that all of like the the
outlines of the building so really the
main pillars but also the observation
deck on the top of it have the sort of
neon stripe ESCA lights on the side of
it to kind of make sure that the
silhouette of the tower is all lit up
like that
I think I might in the future also line
it up a bit more with actual slot lights
or area lights but I quite like the sort
of neon look that the tower has to it
with these kinds of lights and it is
practically impossible to use the planet
coaster spotlights to light up an entire
room 106 meter tall building so that
might still take some kind of
experimentation but really the main
lighting and decoration for the tower
are those sort of neon strips
now what I also wanted to do and this is
something that was sort of a way to try
and cope with the fact that this almost
seemed like it was inevitably going to
be a tower that is just awkwardly put
into the middle of a park and I really
wanted to make sure that the park sort
of develops around the tower and the
tower at least is incorporated in the
park design as a whole so because
because of that I wanted to make sure
that I had some kind of buildings within
foundation base esque thing and that
could connected and really all that I
could come up with that was both kind of
fitting the design of the tower so far
and easy to build would be to build two
sort of quarter circles of buildings
around each side of the tower and make
those a different heights though just
make it a little bit more interesting
and keep them very simple they're really
just sort of neoclassical ish very
minimalistic modern sides that should
hopefully give some sort of some sort of
body to the building of the tower and
not just make it a tower that is
standing in the middle of nowhere and I
really like this technique of building
buildings like being able to rotate
things like anything that isn't a wall
can be rotated in descent and being able
to rotate things like that allows you to
do so many things and save you so much
time when it comes to building anything
beard from domes to run the buildings
like this or anything else wherever you
need a circular shape inside a building
it is usually actually quite easy as
long as you keep in mind through every
step of the building process how
everything connects and make sure that
everything seamlessly connects when you
copy it but as long as you do that all I
really have to do at this point was make
one very small wall section and make
another copy of that slightly change it
raise it up a little bit to make the
higher section and as you can see after
that was done I just have to copy these
things around
and I had the entire base of the round
building and it's pretty much a perfect
part of the circle and all you have to
do at this point is just filling the
bits that are looking ugly and add some
extra detail to it then at this point I
thought I could add to it as well but
it's a very easy way to build stuff in a
way that is very off-grid as well and in
a way that is also very time-saving very
often and it doesn't use too many pieces
I do one of my main goals with building
this tower was to make sure that you can
actually build it as a blueprint so I'll
also be releasing this thing because it
is under 2,000 pieces it is actually
easily under 2,000 pieces and I'll put
it on the workshop and you be able to
download it in the description of this
video or you'll just see it on my steam
page but it's um it's something that is
glue principle and that is actually
quite quite an achievement for me
because usually my buildings consist of
thousands of pieces and as much as I
wish I could put them on the workshop
for most of my most of the buildings
that I'm most happy with I just can't
upload them to the workshop this was
also one of my worries about this park
in general because I was told along with
it's really ranked amel who was also
told to make a park and actually link
that as well because he's also making a
really cool Park basically we're both
making a park for PAX East but what we
were told was that we could probably use
some blueprints of ourselves to make
sure that we can show off what you can
do in planet coaster and to save
ourselves from crime again of making me
Park but there is no way I can actually
feature all of the things that I've made
before as a blueprint which is kind of a
shame because it means that all of the
buildings and theming in this build I'm
going to have to do from the ground up
that said I will be featuring some of
the planet coaster college courses in
here so they'll be quite interesting and
receiving and recoloring some of them as
well
so there is something that's gonna come
back but that aside I'm afraid that I'm
going to have to make all of the
buildings myself and what I also kind of
did is I didn't so much go for a
building style that shows off what I've
done so far because to be very frank
that was just something that I didn't
want to do I much rather just experiment
a bit even if I was in a hurry and even
if I just had to improvise everything I
still wanted to experiment a lot with
stuff so I ended up going for a theme
which well I'm not even sure if you can
call it a theme and I ended up going for
a sort of building style which I haven't
really tried before which you can
clearly see in this tower it isn't
exactly futuristic it is definitely not
sci-fi it's just a modern sort of style
it's a bit of a mishmash of different
things though you'll see that in the the
next episode when I get to the main
street that there are all kinds of
different styles but it's a very general
sort of modern style in a sense I
haven't really done it before which is
kind of handy in a sense that it often
doesn't take that many details and if
you've got a clear idea of what you want
to build at least you can do it somewhat
more quickly then say your building is
super huge detailed castle and also I
guess it just takes away less pieces in
game but modern is is always very a very
difficult kind of theme to go it and I
already know how that some of my
response to what I've done in the park
so far has been kind of mixed it
especially in theme parks where usually
a theme park is kind of a throwback to a
better time some kind of age when
everything was cooler and more
interesting and when we didn't have this
stupid modern arts or things like that
maybe I'm being a bit salty about that
but it's basically it kind of goes
against the idea of the theme park and
even if you have a modern theme in many
theme parks it is either very hyper
modern kind of like a cinema related
Park in from somewhere or a sci-fi is
usually actually an older vision of what
the future would be and this part is
very much just a model
modern kind of style to it but yeah
we'll see how it turns out it's just I
wanted to do some experimentation with
this style and I figured I might as well
try it because the best things that I
have to offer in terms of workshop at
this point are just my roller coasters
and so that is also what quite a lot of
this series will be focusing on anyway
with the building of the tower almost
done with a sort of simple quick round
building on both sides and also a bunch
of like pillar archways that I wanted to
get just to close it up a little bit
more I wanted to get into the pass
system because this will also be quite
interesting I haven't taught this yet
but I was also told to leave of five
open spaces where people could build so
that the idea of the park is kind of
that you can build your own stuff but at
least you're building inside the context
of an already existing theme park you
don't have to worry about making the
guests happy or about having the right
rides that people actually go into the
park but you sort of have that safe
environment to which you can build your
own courses so I have to kind of offer
that with the pike as well so there had
to be some open spaces and for that
reason the past layout is also going to
be quite wide and open with all of these
large grassy areas between it and that's
also sort of the set up of the path area
around the tower here I didn't want to
set it up in a sort of Disney style
where there would be a lake and some
forests and just a small pathway and no
other space but the tower will just kind
of sit in an empty area with much more
grass and open spaces because that's
just where people are going to have to
be able to put in their own things that
said and this is something that I kind
of wanted to keep order in the last part
of the video there is an idea behind
this park and there is an idea behind
the when I'm laying out the parks here
and this weird pond with rocks right
here and that refers back to the title
of this park which even though it's not
very imaginative the elements
to have earth water fire and I guess air
I guess that would kind of work I'm not
too much into Avatar as my apparently
people have been drawing the language
avatar quite a bit but that's not the
inspiration at all I just kind of wanted
to give four different kinds of areas
that you could build in so for example
we have the area on the right bottom
corner with the water and that area is
also just going to have some lakes and
that's going to have some empty spaces
where you can interact with the water
and the earth area is going to have some
caves and a ravine and a canyon stuff
like that where you can interact with
going you know below the the regular sea
level and so that's really idea behind
the park and then the four sort of areas
around the tower are going to be a
reflection of that and that is why I
have the small pond on the side of the
tower here and then the the earth
section is going to have like a small
lower section of ground the the air
section is going to have a mountain
because I didn't want to have actually
floating stuff and Fire is actually
going to refer to some trigger effects
that I wanted to show off over there
obviously flamethrowers because you know
we have flamethrowers in the game might
as well use them I still remember the
first time they were showing off in like
a flame throwing mermaid I believe
something ridiculous like that but yeah
that idea behind the park it is not
necessarily a theme but it is more a way
to show off the various sort of context
in which you can build rides and planet
coaster and to just show off how the
terraforming and everything looks and
planet coaster so basically the design
of this park kind of makes functionality
more important than the way it actually
looks but still I think it can be quite
interesting in the end anyway that is it
for this episode so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next one